du musicien américain Keith Jarrett.
1400 personnes allaient venir.
Et dans à peine quelques heures,
Jarret allait marcher sur cette même scène,
s'asseoir devant le piano
et sans répétition ni partition,
il commencerait à jouer.
Mais à ce moment,
Vera présentait à Keith le piano en question,
et il y avait un hic.
Jarret a regardé l'instrument avec méfiance,
joué quelques notes,
marché autour,
joué d'autres notes,
parlé tout bas à son producteur.
Le producteur est alors allé voir Vera et lui dit :
« Si vous ne trouvez pas un autre piano, Keith ne pourra pas jouer. »
Il y avait eu une erreur.
L'opéra n'avait pas fourni le bon instrument.
Celui-ci avait un registre aigu dur et métallique
parce que le feutre était usé.
Les touches noires étaient collantes,
les touches blanches étaient désaccordées,
les pédales ne marchaient pas
et le piano lui-même était juste trop petit.
Il ne créerait pas le volume
qui remplirait un grand espace tel que l'opéra de Cologne.
Alors, Keith Jarrett partit.
Il alla s'asseoir dans sa voiture,
laissant Vera Brandes
au téléphone, essayant de trouver un piano de remplacement.
Elle trouva un accordeur,
mais pas de nouveau piano.
Elle sortit donc
et elle resta sous la pluie,
parlant avec Keith Jarrett,
lui suppliant de ne pas annuler le concert.
Il regarda de sa voiture
cette adolescente allemande débraillée; trempée par la pluie,
il eut de la peine pour elle,
et lui dit :
« N'oublie jamais... juste pour toi. »
Ainsi, quelques heures plus tard,
Jarrett est effectivement monté sur la scène de l'opéra,
il s'est assis devant le piano injouable
et a commencé.
(Musique)
En quelques instants, il était clair que quelque chose de magique se passait.
Jarrett évitait les registres aigus,
il ne s'en tenait qu'aux médiums,
ce qui donnait à l’œuvre une qualité sonore apaisante.
Mais aussi, puisque le piano était très silencieux,
il devait générer ces bruyants riffs répétitifs dans les graves.
Il se tenait alors debout pendant qu'il tordait et martelait les touches,
essayant de créer assez de volume pour atteindre le dernier rang.
C'est une perfomance survoltée.
Il y a, on ne sait comment, cette qualité apaisante,
et en même temps ça déborde d'énergie,
c'est dynamique.
Le public a adoré.
Le public continue de l'adorer
parce que l'enregistrement du concert de Cologne
est l'album au piano le plus vendu dans l'histoire
et l'album de jazz solo le plus vendu dans l'histoire.
Keith Jarrett s'était retrouvé dans un bazar.
Il a accepté ce bazar et le résultat fut stupéfiant.
Mais revenons un moment sur le premier réflexe de Jarrett.
Il ne voulait pas jouer.
Bien sûr, je pense que
quiconque se trouvant dans une situation un peu similaire,
ressentirait la même chose et aurait le même réflexe.
Nous ne voulons pas avoir à bien travailler avec de mauvais outils.
Nous ne voulons pas avoir à surmonter des obstacles inutiles.
Mais, son instinct l'avait trompé,
et fort heureusement, il a changé d'avis.
Et je pense que notre instinct nous trompe souvent.
Je pense que nous avons besoin de mieux apprécier
les avantages inattendus du fait de devoir faire face à un peu de bazar.
Je vais donc vous citer quelques exemples
tirés de la psychologie cognitive,
des sciences de la complexité,
de la psychologie sociale,
et bien sûr, du rock 'n' roll.
Commençons par la psychologie cognitive.
Nous savons depuis un moment
que certains types de difficultés,
certains types d'obstacles,
peuvent améliorer notre performance.
Par exemple,
le psychologue Daniel Oppenheimer,
il y a quelques années,
s'est associé à des professeurs de lycée.
Il leur a alors demandé de reformater les documents
qu'ils donnaient à certaines de leurs classes.
Le document inital utilisait une police claire et simple,
telle que Helvetica ou Times New Roman.
Mais la moitié des classes a reçu des documents
utilisant une police plus intense, comme Haettenschweiler,
ou quelque chose de plus énergique comme Comic Sans en italique.
Ce ne sont pas des belles polices
et elles sont difficiles à lire.
Mais à la fin du semestre,
les étudiants ont passé leurs examens,
et les étudiants qui ont dû lire les polices complexes
ont mieux réussi leurs examens,
dans plusieurs matières.
La raison à cela
est que la police complexe les avait ralentis,
forcés à travailler un peu plus dur,
à réfléchir un peu plus sur ce qu'ils lisaient,
à l'interpréter...
et ainsi apprendre plus.
Un autre exemple.
La psychologue Shelley Carson a mené des tests sur des étudiants de Harvard
portant sur la qualité de leurs filtres attentionnels.
Qu'entends-je par là ?
Imaginez que vous êtes dans un restaurant,
vous êtes en train de discuter,
il y a toutes sortes de conversations dans le restaurant,
vous voulez les filtrer,
il faut vous concentrer sur le plus important.
Pouvez-vous faire ça ?
Si vous le pouvez, vous avez de bons filtres attentionnels.
Mais certains luttent pour y parvenir.
Certains élèves observés par Carson avaient des difficultés avec cela.
Ils avaient de faibles filtres, des filtres poreux,
qui laissaient passer des informations externes.
J'entends donc par là qu'ils étaient constamment interrompus
par ce qu'ils voyaient et entendaient autour d'eux.
S'il y avait une télé allumée pendant qu'ils travaillaient,
ils ne pouvaient l'ignorer.
On pourrait alors penser que c'est un inconvénient...
eh bien, non.
Quand Carson a examiné ce que les étudiants ont réalisé,
ceux qui avaient de faibles filtres
avaient beaucoup plus de chance
d'avoir de grands moments de créativité dans leur vie,
de publier leur premier roman,
de sortir leur premier album.
En réalité, ces distractions apportent de l'eau à leur moulin créatif.
Ils sortaient des sentiers battus car leur inattention les menait ailleurs.
Passons aux sciences de la complexité.
Comment résoudre un problème complexe,
il y a plein de problèmes compliqués,
comment résoudre un problème vraiment compliqué ?
Prenez par un exemple un moteur à réaction.
Il y a une multitude de variables différentes,
la température, les matériaux,
les différentes dimensions, la forme.
Impossible de résoudre ce type de problème d'un coup,
c'est trop difficile.
Que faites-vous alors ?
Eh bien vous pouvez par exemple le résoudre pas-à-pas.
Vous réalisez un prototype
et vous le réglez, vous le testez et vous l'améliorez.
Vous le réglez, vous le testez et vous l'améliorez.
Cette idée de gains marginaux finira par vous mener à un bon moteur à réaction.
Cette méthode est couramment mise en œuvre dans le monde.
Vous en entendrez parler dans le cyclisme de haute performance,
les web designers disent essayer d'optimiser leurs pages web,
ils cherchent ces gains progressifs.
C'est un bon moyen de résoudre un problème compliqué.
Mais savez-vous ce qui serait un meilleur moyen ?
Un soupçon de désordre.
Ajoutez de l'aléatoire,
très tôt dans le processus,
agissez de façon insensée,
faites des choses stupides qui ne devraient pas marcher
et cela améliorera la tâche de résolution de problème.
La raison à cela est que
le problème avec la démarche pas-à-pas,
les gains marginaux,
c'est qu'ils peuvent vous mener progressivement vers une impasse.
Mais si vous commencez avec du hasard, cela sera moins susceptible d'arriver,
et votre résolution de problème sera plus robuste.
Maintenant, la psychologie sociale.
La psychologue Katherine Phillips, accompagnée de collègues,
a récemment soumis des cas de meurtres mystérieux à certains étudiants,
ces étudiants étaient alors rassemblés en groupes de quatre
et ils ont reçu des dossiers contenant des informations sur un crime,
alibis, preuves, témoignages et trois suspects.
Les groupes d'étudiants devaient essayer de trouver le coupable.
Cette expérience était traitée de deux façons différentes.
Dans certains cas, il s'agissait de quatre amis
qui se connaissaient bien.
Dans d'autres cas,
il y avait trois amis et un inconnu.
Vous pouvez déjà voir où je veux en venir.
Évidemment, je dirai que
les groupes comportant un inconnu ont résolu le problème plus efficacement,
ce qui est vrai en effet.
En fait, ils ont résolu le problème bien plus efficacement.
Ainsi, les groupes de quatre amis,
avaient seulement 1 chance sur 2 de répondre correctement.
Ce n'est pas si bon, sur un QCM de 3 questions
1 chance sur 2 n'est pas bon.
(Rires)
Les trois amis et l'inconnu,
même si l'inconnu n'avait aucune information en plus,
même s'il ne s'agissait
que la facon de changer la conversation pour s'adapter au malaise,
les trois amis et l'inconnu,
avaient 75% de chance de trouver la bonne réponse.
C'est un grand bond en performance.
Mais je pense que ce qui est intéressant,
ce n'est pas tant que les trois amis et l'inconnu avaient mieux travaillé
mais plutôt leur ressenti.
Quand Katherine Phillips a interrogé les groupes de quatre amis,
ils avaient passé un bon moment
et ils avaient pensé avoir bien travaillé.
Ils étaient satisfaits.
Quand elle a parlé aux trois amis et l'inconnu,
ils ne s'étaient pas amusés,
c'était plutôt difficile et gênant
et ils étaient emplis de doutes.
Ils ne pensaient pas avoir bien travaillé même si c'était le cas.
Je pense que ça illustre bien
le défi auquel nous avons affaire.
Parce que, oui,
la police laide,
l'inconnu qui gêne,
l'action aléatoire...
ces perturbations nous aident à résoudre des problèmes,
elles nous aident à devenir plus créatifs.
Mais nous n'en avons pas l'impression.
Nous pensons qu'elles nous ralentissent,
donc nous résistons.
C'est pourquoi mon dernier exemple est très important.
Je veux vous parler de quelqu'un
qui vient des coulisses du monde du rock 'n' roll.
Et vous le connaissiez peut-être, c'est un conférencier TED.
Il s'appelle Brian Eno.
C'est un compositeur, plutôt brillant.
C'est aussi une sorte de catalyseur
à l'origine de certains des grands albums de rock des dernières 40 années.
Il a travaillé avec David Bowie sur « Heroes »,
il a travaillé avec U2 sur « Achtung Baby » et « The Joshua Tree »,
il a travaillé avec DEVO,
il a travaillé avec Coldplay, bref, avec tout le monde.
Que fait-il pour rendre ces groupes de rock meilleurs ?
Eh bien, il crée du désordre.
Il perturbe leurs processus créatifs.
C'est son rôle d'être l'inconnu gênant.
C'est son rôle de leur dire
qu'ils doivent jouer du piano injouable.
Et une des façons qu'il a de créer cette perturbation
est d'utiliser cet étonnant jeu de cartes.
J'ai mon jeu de cartes dédicacé ici. Merci, Brian.
On les appelle les Stratégies Obliques,
il les a developpées avec un ami.
Quand ils ont un blocage au studio,
Brian Eno va aller chercher une carte.
Il en tire une au hasard,
et il dit au groupe de suivre les instructions de la carte.
Celle-ci, par exemple...
« Échangez les instruments. »
Tout le monde échange ses instruments. Batteur au piano...
Brillante, brillante idée.
« Regardez de près les détails les plus embarassants. Amplifiez-les. »
« Faites une action soudaine, destructive et imprévisible. Intégrez-la. »
Ces cartes sont perturbantes.
Cependant, elles ont fait leurs preuves, album après album.
Les musiciens les détestent.
(Rires)
Phil Collins était ainsi batteur sur un des premiers albums de Brian Eno.
Il était tellement frustré qu'il jetait des canettes de bière à travers le studio.
Carlos Alomar, grand guitariste de rock,
travaillant avec Eno sur l'album « Lodger » de David Bowie,
s'est tourné vers Brian à un moment et lui a dit :
« Brian, cette expérience est stupide. »
Mais le fait est que c'était un album plutôt bon,
mais en plus,
Carlos Alomar, 35 ans plus tard, utilise les Stratégies Obliques.
Il conseille même à ses étudiants de les utiliser
car il a constaté quelque chose.
Ce n'est pas parce que vous n'aimez pas quelque chose, que cela ne vous aide pas.
Les Stratégies n'étaient pas un jeu de cartes à l'origine,
il s'agissait d'une liste
sur le mur du studio d'enregistrement.
Une liste de choses à essayer si vous aviez un blocage.
La liste ne marchait pas.
Vous savez pourquoi ?
Pas assez désordonné.
Votre œil parcourait la liste
et s'arrêtait sur la proposition la moins perturbante,
la moins problématique,
ce qui fait évidemment perdre tout son intérêt à la liste.
Ce que Brian Eno a fini par comprendre, c'est que,
oui, il faut mettre en œuvre ces expériences stupides,
il faut faire face à des étrangers gênants,
il faut essayer de lire les polices laides.
Ces choses nous aident.
Elles nous aident à résoudre des problèmes
et à être plus créatifs.
Mais aussi...
nous avons besoin de conviction pour accepter cela.
Et peu importe le moyen...
que ce soit de par notre simple volonté,
ou en tirant une carte
ou une adolescente allemande qui vous fait culpabiliser,
nous avons tous, de temps en temps,
besoin de nous asseoir et d'essayer de jouer de ce piano injouable.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)